[Musique]
et pour en parler avec moi en direct
chems eddine hafiz nouveau recteur de la
grande mosquée de paris bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
georges kuzmanovic président de la
république souveraine bonsoir georges
intro semaine au beach merci d'être avec
nous également alors chems eddine hafiz
vous êtes l'inde et l'une des fers de
lance de ce combat vous avez eu des mots
assez durs dans votre communiqué vous
demander instamment aux pouvoirs publics
que la réouverture donc des cultes soit
avancée au 24 mai son pêne d'user de
tous les moyens légaux pour vous est-ce
que c'était un temps approprié
bonsoir d'abord oui c'était le ton
approprié parce que depuis le début de
cette pandémie en france les musulmans
de france se sont alignés aux décisions
politiques et sanitaires qui ont été
prononcées par par les autorités et à ce
titre là les musulmans de france se sont
consacrés d'abord en tant que citoyens à
vivre dans le confinement à l'instar de
tous les citoyens français et au moment
de du début du ramadan
lorsque moi j'avais entendu le président
de la république parler du 2 juin
j'avais annoncé aux fidèles musulmans
que durant le mois du ramadan il y
allait avoir deux événements importants
qui se pratique d'habitude c'est les ce
qu'on appelle les prières surérogatoires
taraweeh après la rupture du jeûne et
pendant la soirée la récitation du coran
des ran imams et la prière collective du
vendredi et j'avais annoncé qu'en tout
état de cause le 23 ou 24 mai date de la
fin du jeûne du ramadan
il n'y aurait pas de prières de l'aïd et
moi à titre personnel j'avais indiqué
que la grande mosquée de paris et les
mosquées qui
sont attachés à la grande mosquée de
paris vient à peu près 250 noeuds nous
ne nous ouvrir et pas leurs portes d'ici
le mois de septembre compte tenu de la
situation extrêmement complexe mais j'ai
été extrêmement surpris lorsque j'ai
appris que le premier ministre
songez à permettre à compter du 29 mai
donc de laisser à l'intérieur de
certains lieux de culte célébrer les
fêtes
donc comme vous avez dit de produits d
de pentecôte catholique et protestante
moi j'ai sursauté en disant mais comment
se fait-il que à ce titre là le premier
ministre oublie quand même une
composante de la société française qui
sont les musulmans mais bien évidemment
il n'est pas question d'ouvrir les lieux
de culte pour les ouvrir il s'ouvrira un
lieu de culte
lorsqu'on est pratiquement certain de
pouvoir respecter scrupuleusement les
règles de distanciation sociale et de
gestes barrières moi personnellement en
tant que recteur de la grande mosquée de
paris celle d'auch qui est au 5e
arrondissement paris je sais
pertinemment que je ne pourrais pas
ouvrir parce qu'il faut savoir on va y
revenir justement sur ces mesures de
sécurité mais j'aimerais quand même fait
réagir georges consommer nos vies tch on
a écouté l'explication est ce que vous
comprenez cela georges crossmen beach la
colère effectivement de chems eddine
hafiz si nous étions dans un contexte
normal je m'opposerai au fait qu'un
représentant de culte veuille imposer
une date pour une réouverture des de ces
lieux de culte en fonction des besoins
de sa religion de tels doite dates
doivent être déterminées par la raison
et donc par des considérations
sanitaires et logistique
ça tombe sous le sens mais dans le cas
précis je d'une certaine manière je
comprends la position de monsieur hafiz
car nous sommes dans une situation quand
même très particulière donc ça tout le
monde voit bien que ce gouvernement
géré d'une manière catastrophique cette
crise du comique 19
on va pas revenir sur tout sur tout les
problèmes mais juste les dates on sait
maintenant que la date du déconfinement
a été choisie d'une manière assez
hasardeuse que le premier ministre
lui-même n'avait pas l'air informé 15
minutes avant l'annoncé que ce serait le
11 mai on sait également comme vous
l'avez dit que monsieur le président
d'un pays française monsieur macron a
initié des visioconférences avec et les
cultes donc il en discussion avec les
cultes donc j'imagine monsieur la fise
est que chacun a dû faire les remarques
correspondant aux besoins de sa religion
donc il est tout à fait étonnant de se
retrouver dans une situation où à
nouveau sur un terrain plat il n'y a
donc aucune nécessité ce gouvernement
crée un problème entre différentes
groupes religieux dans notre société
en annonçant un jour une date et
pourquoi pas le 2 juin 6 et 6 essence et
quand on sait la peur pour vous le
gouvernement a cédé aux pressions
notamment des catholiques qui ne s'en
sont pas cachés qui souhaitait au moins
la réouverture pour les fêtes de
pentecôte pour vous clairement ça a été
ce qui a expliqué cette différence entre
le 2 juin et le 29 mai non je considère
surtout que ce gouvernement ne gouverne
pas été capable de prendre des décisions
sur des considérations purement un
raisonnable que sur celle des questions
sanitaires
je tiens également par contre a critiqué
la démarche initiée par monsieur macron
c'est visioconférence avec les cultes
qui peuvent se comprendre dans un
contexte de crises et de graves
problèmes pour les familles de mener
lors des fins à la tombe et que comment
organiser les cérémonies funéraires
mais nous avons appris que cette que ces
réunions allait perdurer et que monsieur
macron qui est censé être le garant des
valeurs de la république
l'article 1 est temps que la piste
française et sociale et laïque veut en
faire une sorte de conseil
pour aider à la cohésion du pays et se
donner les moyens de rebondir en sortie
de crise dans ce qu'il appelle sa
nouvelle société
c'est tout à fait ahurissant rld et les
religions mais laure vit l endroit de
fer sont protégés par la laïcité
on voit là la dérive anti laïque du
président de la république qui mais
c'est une continuité c'est pas quelque
chose qui est née là il l'avait déjà dit
face aux évêques au collège des
bernardins lorsqu'il avait dit nous
souhaitons donc renouer le lien rompu
avec l'église mais sans comprendre que
justement le lien a été rompu en 1905 et
que l'idée n'est pas de le renouer
spécifiquement avec une religion
particulière exactement pardonnez moi
cette vision conférence avec tous les
responsables du culte on a bien compris
ce qui vous trouble et vous voilà vous
et vous estimiez discriminés il
n'empêche ces religions qui font
pression le président qui discute
est ce que les religions ne sont pas un
petit peu trop puissants devant
justement comme l'a dit jean jacques aux
mains de wisches dans un pays tout
simplement laïque où on ne devrait pas
avoir à faire état de ce genre de
situation finalement ce que vous
comprenez ces critiques
moi je comprends ces critiques mais il
ya quelques nuances à apporter d'abord
la laïcité n'interdit pas de d'être en
relation avec les religions il y as je
vous rappelle au ministère de
l'intérieur un bureau central des cultes
qui est chargée notamment d'avoir des
relations et des liens avec les
différents responsables des cultes
moi ce que je veux dire dans cette
affaire alors je cherche ni à imposer
quoi que ce soit
moi je réagis en tant que citoyen moi ce
que je voudrais qu'on comprenne
aujourd'hui ma démarche c'est le citoyen
qui d'abord s'exprime à travers la
déclaration faite par le premier
ministre moi je suis avocat de formation
j'ai pour principe l'equilibre de 2,2
des citoyens devant la loi y ait une
égalité il y à une égalité des citoyens
devant la loi quelle que soit notre
statut que nous soyons religieux ou pas
que nous soyons femmes aux hommes que
nous soyons noir ou blanc il y à un
principe aujourd'hui qui fait le contrat
social français c'est que nous sommes
tous égaux et il n'y a pas de différence
du fait d'un élément qui peut
éventuellement nous disent nous
différencier par rapport aux autres
consiste à dire clairement combien
comprennent vous sentez tout simplement
lésés par rapport aux communautés juives
et catholiques qui pourrait affecter
leur fait à la fin du mois de mai tout
simplement c'est la salle au fond du
problème si on vous suit bien mais bien
sûr et c'est à vous de me le dire
comment expliquer scientifiquement il
n'a pas su dire non non b
scientifiquement aujourd'hui nous savons
que nous vivons une grave crise
sanitaire et je partage le point de vue
de notre intervenant qui effectivement
montre l'amateurisme des hommes
politiques qui aujourd'hui gouverne la
france aujourd'hui ce qui est important
pour moi c'est que je voudrais
comprendre que le président pourquoi le
président ma croix fixée le 2 juin il y
à peine une dizaine de jours pour
permettre au culte de célébrer à
l'intérieur des églises des synagogues
des temples et des mosquées leur leur
propre fait
comment se fait-il que par hasard le 2
juin a été avancée au 29 mai alors moi
je lève la main en disant attention il y
a quand même une communauté musulmane
qui n'a rien demandé c'est certain qu'il
fera tout pour éviter la prob à la
propagation du coc u19 à travers ces
mosquées mais en tout état de cause
expliquez moi il y a une différence à
peine de quatre jours du 24 au 29 mai
pourquoi le vous pensez que le 28 mai à
minuit à ce moment là il n'y aura plus
de coronavirus nous sommes soient en
état de guerre
soit il peut y avoir à un moment ou un
autre des idées système dérogatoire
c'est à dire même face à la guerre il y
à un système dérape
et rogatoire qui est complètement est
supportable je vous rappelle que le pape
lui même n'était pas du tout satisfait
par la démarche qui a été fait par les
évêques français donc aujourd'hui raison
garder moi je réagis simplement comme
citoyen et jacky je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour que le religieux reste à
sa place en france il ya eu suffisamment
de souffrance dans ce pays pour on est
arrivé à la loi de 1905
vous ne verrez jamais en tout cas de ma
bouche demander des dérogations et de
man et donner des coups de qualif à la
laïcité pour moi je considère que la
laïcité est un trésor commun que nous
devons tous préservés par des lois c'est
le modef a porté l affaire devant les
tribunaux si ça devait rester en l'état
c'est bien cela absolument sur le
principe du de l'equilibre de de
l'égalité entre citoyens qui est pour
moi très cher à mes yeux le modef a
rapidement georges consommer dovic à
bout encore une fois la démarche de
monsieur hafiz me semble sensé dans le
contexte ubuesque dans laquelle nous
placent à nouveau le gouvernement
n'avait pas besoin de ça il annonce une
date
quand on prend une décision on s'y tient
il a choisi de juin le choisit de joie
monsieur hafiz il me semble n'a pas fait
une démarche par rapport aux deux
joueurs il aurait pu peut-être une revue
l'ensemble des cultes dire ah mais non
nous c'est le 24e si les 29es ce que
pouvait pas avancer d'une semaine ce
serait sympathique et le gouvernement
aurait pu répondre non messieurs nous
avons choisi le 2 parce que
sanitairement c'est le 2e est que nous
avons besoin d'un but de mettre en place
des effectifs
or c'est pas ça qui s'est passé donc a
priori on peut supposer que dans son
désir renouer des relations avec les
cultes
peut-être peut-être que monsieur
maquereau a subi une pression monsieur
philippe puisqu'il ne se parle pas
exactement on n'a pas l'air de se parler
monde en ce moment
et voilà ils ont décidé bon va falloir
qu'on va faire le 29 en créant un
problème communautariste qui n'avait
qu'il n'ait pas lieu d'être
qui sort de nulle part par leur propre
incompétence de grévy en tout cas
puisque c'est dans ce contexte que
légitime merci en tout cas à tous les
deux
chems eddine hafiz et georges kauffmann
hobbit avoir été avec nous en direct